- [Narrator] It's November 6th, 1814.
In the Belgian city of Dinant,
in a modest house built
on a street that would
later bear his name,
- [Adolphe Voiceover] Hello.
- [Narrator] Adolphe Sax was born.
28 years later while living in Paris,
Sax would invent the saxophone
and revolutionize music
in ways he couldn't imagine.
But this isn't that
story, this is the story
of how Adolphe Sax
escaped death seven times
before inventing the saxophone.
Hardly old enough to
stand, the young Adolphe
fell down three flights of stairs.
A stone floor broke his fall.
At the age of three, Adolphe swallowed
a bowl of watered-down sulphuric acid,
mistaking it for milk.
Years later, Adolphe found himself
a bit too close to a gunpowder explosion.
He was again burned when
a cast iron frying pan
was not knocked over onto him.
Later, a roof stone fell on his head,
leaving a life-long scar.
Adolphe was nearly asphyxiated
when recently varnished
items were left in his bedroom overnight.
He woke up, barely.
Playing with friends in a nearby river,
Adolphe was swept up in a swift
current and nearly drowned.
Again, he survived.
On February 7th, 1894, Adolphe
died peacefully in Paris.
The saxophone had already
crossed the Atlantic,
prime to evolve into an
icon of American jazz music
and guaranteeing Sax his immortality.
(jazz background music)